hey how are you how are you doing
nothing makes sense anymore are you okay
Daisy broke up well it's gonna be okay
you're right Clarence I want you to meet
keanue ice your door open be honest I'm
sorry
oh stop stop bro I'm here cuz my place
got broken into there's anyone Shady
come by here I mean there's 17 street
blips the 17th big lips okay where are
they
17th Street let's just go check it out
what's the worst that can happen
one beer please I'll take a white wines
with clear skies what you can't talk
like that here then we really are in
trouble because you sound like Sean
Ritter all the time well ah beg to
differ
[ __ ] went straight to the n-word [ __ ]
in a right way do in a bright place
nickel oh we in the market right now for
like a gangster pet so the [ __ ]
I hate not breaking the lab we just feed
him some [ __ ] about New Jack city we
get killed
you might never see nobody good kid
are you [ __ ] what do you think my idea
fun was why are you talking to me like
that I talk like that sometimes why you
dry this weekend has been we want to
never get pulled over again
you gotta inconspicuous bad in your
vehicle ain't no dang
see what we got here what the [ __ ] is
this oh this must [ __ ] right here
yeah what was that I should kill
everyone in escape sorry
the voices I'm kidding that's not what
they really